Justin starts this hour up in Cincinnati
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Justin
hey thank you day thanks for taking my
call big fan thank you how can I help so
I'll get right to my wife has been going
back to school she didn't have quite the
opportunity that I did since we had a
kid early so we recently decided a year
and a half ago to give her the
opportunity to go back to school which
we you know ignorant Lee decided to take
on more debt to do that but we it was a
decision we made at the time and we kind
of stuck with it my question is where
I'm baby set to right now and we're just
trying to figure all this out but I want
to I want to keep her in school because
it's kind of the next step as far as our
career I will help us longer term but I
also want to get out of debt and I don't
want to keep taking on student loans to
do that I'm just curious what your
advice was mmm that's a pickle okay well
to start with we're going to start with
the foundational principle that Dave
Ramsey never tell somebody to go into
debt so we got to start there because I
wouldn't go into debt and so I'm not
gonna tell you to but I got you
definitely got a real mess here so what
what is she studying her major is
biology she's finishing a biology degree
in order to do what she either once the
world and then research or something
with animals it's comics she's not
spread right now but you said further
her career does she know I'm just really
pissed our whole career in he stays at
home right now my son and how old is she
she's 28 years old okay and how much
does it take how much does she lack time
one is how many more years to finish her
degree she's finishing up her second
year right now and at the rate she's
going it will probably take another
three and half years
okay and what does it cost a year it'll
probably cost us host 30 25 a year
I'm saying out a year Oh another another
15 to 23 years okay and what do you make
gross 120 okay and how much debt do you
guys have not counting your home about
52,000 and how much do you own your cars
I always have one all I came right now
is just how are those couple weeks ago
and it's 25,000 okay when did you tell
me you started all this stuff just get
out of that stuff for years now and
we've been sadly said yes a loosely
doing it and thinking we could do it on
land that didn't work yeah apparently
loosely like not at all right 25 our car
in this equation would be like freaking
insanity wait wait okay um I mean you
knew that when you called me right so
you need to decide my you need the first
thing you guys are gonna have to decide
is when you actually are going to start
working this proven process if you're
not it's okay you can I you know I can
still be friends I got lots of friends
that borrow money and don't do my stuff
that's okay we'll still be friends okay
but if you're gonna work this process
you're gonna have to decide that you're
gonna do it and you and your wife you
and your wife together have to have to
sit down and make that decision and and
I can tell by talking to you that
decision has not been made this will
have a wake up call
what oh it was never in the original
plan so you like got home and we're
stupid pretty much yeah sell it that's
not going yeah yeah I mean not really
appreciated pencil bottle but you know
all the rest of the conversation aside
if I make a huge mistake and I have the
ability to undo it with some damage but
we're near the damage of keeping it I'm
just gonna undo that mistake that that's
that's a starter right there then we can
go and deal with 15,000 a year out of
120 thousand dollar income to cash flow
your wife's college and no more student
loans sure you can make that happen
mm-hmm because half of your debt is your
wife's car that you just bought yet the
sort of cost of the part she's
struggling with with the car is and I'm
ready to sell it because it's just it's
destroying our you know we're robbing
our future here but she's struggling
because we just we pay taxes and
everything on top of it so obviously
you're you're at a minimum you leaving
the school three thousand dollars he
paid in taxes when I'm yeah in the grand
scheme of things is when you're gonna
have to decide dude you're gonna have to
decide and maybe you're starting to
decide but I'm not even sure she's on
this planet yet the deciding planet
because right now what I hear is a lady
who wants to go to school so we're going
to school I want a car so I'm getting
the car anything else I want I'm just
gonna go do and oh by the way while
you're doing that let's get out of debt
too
nope not gonna happen not gonna happen
so I don't know if she grew up spoiled
but her husband is spoiling her I can
tell you that so um yeah car's gone
we're gonna cash flow school beans and
rice everybody that's an adult under
your roof is working and everything else
is up for sale too and we're gonna get
this mess cleaned up and we're gonna pay
cash for school do we want to pay a
price to get a biology degree or is this
just a little luxury we're going after
you guys gotta decide you can borrow
yourself up here a dadgum highballs
you've proven that now you're just gonna
go forward or not you gotta decide man
you guys thought I can't do this for you
I can't do it for you I can't want it
for you more than you want it I can't
make you do it so you guys have to
decide and there's nothing in this
conversation that indicates either one
of you are close so just go out to get
mad about it not at each other but you
know just get this guy
and we're gonna clean this mess up we're
gonna start being adults and say no no
we can't afford this no we're not going
on vacation no we're not gonna eat in a
restaurant no no no no so that we can
say yes we're gonna live like no one
else so that later we can live like no
one else so that we can get a biology
degree that's a fine degree go get the
degree I got no issue with that but pay
cash for it no we're not doing it let's
we pay cash for it no we make one
hundred twenty thousand dollars a year
and we're broke people you had a sign
man you got to decide and I'm more
disgusted for you right now not at you
but I'm for you than you are you can do
this but only you and her can do this